The jogan Experience well I'm going to
be as honest as I can with you I'm not
trying to be cute here okay I lost my
eyesight when I stopped doing coke cuz
when I was doing coke my eyesight was on
point CH I could see a light from
[__] two miles away that light's
green we got to make it once I stopped
doing coke my eyesight went right into
the [__] [__] so when I was
snorting I had 2020 Vision I could see
Coke rocks and the carpet and [__] now I
can't see [__] if there's a Coke Rock on
the [__] floor so guess it's blood
flow if you think about it blood flow to
the brain I mean doesn't Coke give you
like a crazy amount of blood flow to
your brain I mean must it's a stimulant
no idea I have no idea where the blood
goes thank God I never got into that no
thank God I never got into and
especially now like now I see these
people that are snorting anything yeah
to snort anything today you got to be
[__] crazy yeah you can die heroin
these people who put the [__] test
like if you go to a bar in New York they
have test yeah that you go in the
bathroom and are you [__] kidding me
they have to once you test cocaine it's
time to do something different you got
to test your Coke it's time to do
something different you got to [__]
you know what's going on here ketamine
everybody's doing ketamine they do nasal
sprays we had some lady going into a
khole in the middle of our comedy
show she's [__] falling down like
this and they brought in the Naran and
[__] they were worried that she had
overdosed and her wife's like no no no
she's just been doing Kine she just did
too much she did a couple lines of that
one time at the podcast Studio yeah and
it was okay I did the podcast but
whoever gave me to camine left like a
pile of it on the desk you know after we
did a couple lines so he left and me and
Lee were talking and I go Lee what are
we going to do with this [__] thing
he I don't know throw it away I go [__]
that it was about 8:30 9:00 at night I
had done three lines maybe and I was
buzzed but it didn't take me over the
top I did those now I lived
six minutes from the podcast studio and
all when I got to the first light to
make the left I knew it was not going to
be a good drive home it was not going to
be a good drive home okay I had done too
much and then I got home and when I put
my foot out of the car that was it it
was lights out after that and I'm like I
am [__] up I'm what do you mean like
lights out like what way like I was
[__] up I don't know what was going on
it's a different kind of [__] up right
a different type of [__] up and then I
went in the house and godamn it my wife
is awake oh no now I got to talk to
her so I ran in my office and I'm in
there 15 minutes getting higher and
higher oh no and [__] my body's feeling
weird and I go I better go out there
before she comes and hit
right and she was watching True True
Crimes detective whatever that on HBO oh
okay and it was the dude from the green
book and the other guy the green book
the brother the the guy who won the he
was book the green book with the guy who
drove him in the South he played the
piano play anyway it doesn't matter so
you never saw the green book I don't
think I saw GRE good [__] movie we
were talking about him yesterday Marshal
Al Ali yeah yeah that guy's awesome man
he's awesome he was great in that
Netflix documentary or the Netflix show
we were just talking about about the end
of the world with Julia Roberts and
Ethan Hawk oh I didn't see that it was
good good [__] y hated it though huh
yeah he's trying to get me to hate it I
kind of went with him a little bit right
he influenced me I was like yeah there
was some parts I didn't like yeah you
didn't like the animals the CG animals
get picky yeah bunch of CGI animals
staring at people I'm like come on no
you don't need to do this to me no no
but I looked at him and while I was
watching TV his head kept getting bigger
and I'm like I couldn't take it I'm
sitting there I got no t-shirt on I'm
sweating confucious she's kind of
looking at me I'm I'm kind of looking at
her your wife is a [__] angel and
finally she really is I could take it no
more I couldn't take it no more I go
what the hell's going on here and she's
like what what I'll change it she didn't
know I told her the next morning I said
let me tell you something when I came
last night I was not doing too good you
know people think that you you [__]
around like when I was living in La
people think like you [__] around and
you don't have no everybody always
thinks like I just got high and had no
[__] consequences I just never told
you about what I dealt with you know one
not I mushrooms and I went home and the
[__] mushrooms hit I didn't know I
ate like three little [__] things at
the office the mushrooms hit and that's
the day The Exorcist came on and I had
to watch it and I'm like what the and I
finally ran into the room and put the
blankets over my head it was too [__]
real like I have horrible High stories I
just don't repeat them cuz you know
people won't believe them I remember
when we were on a plane once and you
were eating stars at death and uh we
were like almost at New York and it was
like an hour before the plane land Joe
Rogan I almost [__] lost it I almost
[__] lost it I was having a pan
attack I was it was getting bad it was
getting bad then you go but I'm back and
then you pop two more I'm like how did
you just [__] do that you just had a
panic attack almost you know for three
years I cried about this anxiety anxiety
I can't take it yeah [__] I don't do
Edibles now is that what it is Monday
nights so was it Edibles that was giving
you the anxiety you said it yourself you
can't live a 2,000 Mig a goddamn day
something's got to fall apart eventually
yeah you know that was kicking it up and
then I would get anytime I would get
above 200 milligrams the whole world was
just like very slippery very slippery I
like this is like I could see how
Edibles can get someone to legitimately
lose their
mind